Queen Elizabeth begins her final Journey
her coffin made its way to Westminster
Abbey
a full military guard accompanied The
Departed Monarch part of an ancient
ceremony combining Church State and the
Royal Family's history
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Elizabeth's grandchildren followed her
into the Abbey
foreign
[Music]
by her son King Charles III and the
queen consort Camilla
the dean of Westminster Abbey introduced
the service here where Queen Elizabeth
was married and crowned
We Gather from across the nation
from the Commonwealth and from the
nations of the world
to mourn our loss
to remember her long life of selfless
service and ensure confidence to commit
her to the mercy of God our maker and
Redeemer
Come Ye blessed Redemption my father and
Remembrance
[Music]
Britain's prime minister Liz truss was
confirmed by the queen just two days
before her death she read a lesson from
the Bible I will come again and receive
you unto myself
that where I am there ye may be
the Archbishop of Canterbury paid
tribute to the Queen's lifelong mission
her late Majesty famously declared
on a 21st birthday broadcast that her
whole life would be dedicated to serving
the nation and Commonwealth
rarely
has such a promise been so well kept
few leaders
receive the outpouring of love that we
have seen
Our Father who art in heaven Hallowed
a Fanfare and the nation fell silent for
two minutes foreign
ERS paid tribute to their new monarch
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
headed for her final resting place
[Music]
those events of course happened this
morning and the queen had just just uh
had the committal service in Saint
George's Chapel in Windsor where my
colleague Jack parrick is standing by
um Jack
what was it like during that ceremony in
in Windsor you've been there all day uh
what's the mood then
we've just had some of the dignitaries
actually that were within St George's
Chapel there are actually many of them
leaving up this road as they've exited
that service obviously the Queen's body
now goes to be interred in a private
ceremony with just the family in
attendance I think it was a a really
really powerful ceremony and one of the
things that's stood out and we've heard
people talking about is this this image
of the king with clear tears in his eyes
I absolute sadness you can see it on his
face and at the end of the day well this
is a monarch you know monarchy changing
hands from the queen to the king it is
also the funeral of his mother it's been
a quite a powerful moment and also one
of the things I think that people have
been very impressed with and we know the
queen herself had a strong hand in is
the music of the ceremonies rousing uh
sort of angelic choral music in
especially in in Westminster Abbey
earlier and more somber music during the
committal service that's just taken
place here in Windsor as I say now this
moves on to a very private Affair we saw
the Royals leaving the chapel and they
will now head up shortly for that
committal ceremony where Prince Charles
the Queen's form uh late husband is also
is also buried
uh now Jack we've seen such an
outpouring of support
do you think this bodes well for the
future of the British Monarchy
I think they'll probably say that it
will themselves I think that they will
uh hope I hope I think that this funeral
and this week's uh plus long of mourning
for the for the queen these five days
lying in state with so many thousands of
people going to pay their respects will
show that in this country there is a
huge amount of support for the monarchy
there are always questions about their
position they hold political position as
the the constitutional monarchy a
functional position to allow the
parliament to act as as the The
Authority the Democratic Authority here
in the country and I think what we've
seen is a really big event that the
Royals have put on the media have
obviously been in full attendance from
all over the world here in Windsor and
and in Westminster and at Westminster
Abbey et cetera and I think that they
will feel that what they've done is
shown the The Best of British firstly
for the queen and also for the
International Community and that is part
of their role to to be on show this is a
private Affair this is a funeral for
their family but it is also a symbolic
funeral for the country and for the
world now you mentioned politics earlier
which has virtually come to a standstill
during her uh the lying uh in state of
the of the late uh Queen uh tomorrow is
uh and the start of a new era if you
will politically as well uh what's on
the agenda
a lot of things get out you're
absolutely right to say the the death of
the queen and prior to that the
leadership race for the conservative
party that has resulted in this trust
becoming prime minister has meant that
there's been pretty much nothing
happening politically at a time when
Energy prices are soaring other blocks
the European Union the Americans and
indeed all over the world parliaments
and governments have been racing to try
and tackle that issue and there is
absolutely no question that Liz trust
will get into her office tomorrow and
after all of this pageantry all of this
pause that has happened in this country
will be racing to try and make changes
to try and sort out what Britain is
going to do about that energy crisis the
people that have been out on the streets
uh you know maybe paying their respects
to the queen but they'll also be paying
their bills in the coming months that
are that are going up by three-digit
percentage percents you know to 100 150
in some cases and that is really the top
of the entry for Liz trust the new prime
minister that really hasn't done
anything you know the queen died only
two days after she she invested her
jackpack there wins a castle thank you
very much Jack
and coming back to the studio here Robin
Merrell is still with me uh wrap it up
for us your final thoughts about today's
events well an extraordinary day for an
extraordinary woman it has to be said
I'm full of Pomp and pageantry as I said
I agree with Jack the music was quite
magnificent I particularly spoke about
the the bagpipers which really was a
very emotional um there's a certain
amount of gratefulness I I had a feeling
the gratefulness for her service over 70
years and ex celebration of of an
extraordinary life of service and a
fitting farewell to the Elizabethan era
Robin Merrell thank you very much
now the death of Queen Elizabeth has
triggered an outpouring of sentiment in
Hong Kong as well one of the last former
British colonies which was handed over
to China 25 years ago the collective
grief is not just about mourning the
late Queen though it's also about
remembering what many of you as the
Golden Era of Hong Kong but even that
Nostalgia is becoming taboo on the
Chinese rule as our correspondent Phoebe
King reports
since the Queen's passing a shop-selling
British colonial Hong Kong items such as
coin stems and medals is welcoming 10
times more customers than usual it's
founded by Brian Ong the royalty
collector didn't expect people coming
for TFO commemoration
they feel like they're losing an old
friend or even a family member
she's more than a queen
it's also because life in Hong Kong
wasn't that good in the past two decades
with retrogression in many ways
people miss the past not because they
like or want colonism but purely because
it was the good old days
I think that's being reflected through
mourning the queen
such sentiments are more visible at the
British Consulate surrounded by a sea of
flowers people are curing for up to four
hours in the heat to sign the book of
condolences the colonial era is still in
many people's memories in Hong Kong
which was ruled by Britain for 156 years
before its Handover to China in 1997.
the most precious thing Britain left us
is a social system with lots of freedoms
to pursue our goals
the education was better we were happier
less stressed and restricted
Britain didn't give us much in the way
of democracy but overall it did more
good than harm
Hong Kong people gave the queen a
Cantonese nickname the boss lady showing
a special affection the outpouring of
mourning is not only a matter of
nostalgia but mixed with Grievances and
this content over the Chinese Rule and
even a gesture of defying the current
repression
the queen visited Hong Kong twice during
the 70s and 80s when social reforms were
rolled out after anti-colonial riots to
transform the small City into a world
financial Hub today public facilities
named after Queen Elizabeth are Marcus
of Britain's Legacy to Modern Hong Kong
Hong Kong was one of few British
colonies not allowed to determine its
own future
born in 1980 and educated in colonial
government schools Brian Ong said he was
never taught to be a British Patriots
last year he opened a private Museum
this certificate signed by the queen and
Prince Philip is among the most precious
in His 10 000 item collection
I've never considered myself British I'm
100 a hong konger who loves British
culture all
histories are meaningful whenever they
happened no matter good or bad we
shouldn't erase any part of it just
because we don't like it
all of us should respect our past
is not only to preserve relics but also
the identity of his hometown